bonjour je vais vous parler du film
nightcall sorti en 2014 et c'est un film
réalisé par Dan duroll alors ici nous
sommes sur un film sombre et axé sur les
chasseurs de scoop à Los Angeles avec
comme acteur principal Jake Gillian qui
interprète justement ce chasseur de
scoop et on va avoir vraiment une
performance d'acteurs grandissime son
personnage va évoluer d'heure en heure
dans le film c'est mélanger avec une
réalisation sombre un peu nocturne avec
un étalonnage un travail de la lumière
accompagnant cette évolution de
personnage un peu dans l'univers drive
avec Ryan Gosling on est sur une volonté
ici de l'acteur de réussir réussir mais
à quel point il va vraiment vouloir les
de plus en plus loin aller chercher des
détails mais justement jusqu'à quel
point ça je vous laisserai le découvrir
on peut parler du coup de frénésie un
peu de ce qui nous offre émis du
personnage et on peut vraiment parler je
pense d'une sorte de thriller
psychologique qui est vraiment à
découvrir